i want to stay on the the the uh the
january 6 topic we have the story from
newsweek biden starts 2022 trailing
trump by average of nearly five points
in 2024 election polls now i would like
you to all enter the world view of the
establishment left they believe that
donald trump staged a military coup and
failed they believe that donald trump
staged an insurrection and failed they
believe that he is currently trying to
engage in another coup and another
insurrection the atlantic rights trump's
next coup has already begun january 6
was practice donald trump's gop is much
better positioned to subvert the next
election
combine these stories and you will start
to see a variant is this the one where
it's like you know people are running
for local precinct care and stuff but
look there's another story that we
talked about on the show a few weeks ago
where it says the trump conspiracy is
still continuing
if the atlantic if these mainstream
publications genuinely believe that
trump is actively engaging in the
subversion of u.s democracy it means
that the polls show
more americans favor the insurrection
and the coup than the establishment
government well i have a um i have a i
have a thing on this and i was i was
kind of joking around on twitter
yesterday and i said you know all of the
headlines make sense if you re if you
can learn to speak regime english
and
english yeah i figured you'd like that
one and uh so if you speak regime glitch
so and i i lifted this bit from um from
adrian vermeuel and i don't usually make
it a habit of quoting harvard professors
but you know he's kind of like a token
you know good guy so i'll quote him and
he said when they say democracy they
really mean liberalism right so just
always always substitute the word you
know trump is a threat to democracy
trump is a threat to liberalism just
thinking to subvert democracy trump is
seeking to subvert liberalism you see
that but i don't i don't think
liberalism is the right word because
they're a cult it's just something
entirely the liberal economic order that
the liberal orders did you see that clip
that went viral where you know they're
like the republicans are a threat to
democracy because they might win
elections yeah this is it's not a coup
when you unseat a sitting president
through votes and win the election
that's a natural way that it functions
it might seem cool
because it's a new guy coming in
they they have right in their own mind
they have gone so far into their own
you could use the phrase of the day mass
formation psychosis where they actually
believe that democracy and liberalism
are synonymous that they're the same
thing there can be no other order and
this of course is not just a mass
formation psychosis thing this this is
actually religious belief right you know
there can only be one true religion so
if there can only be one true order then
anything that that arises that's a
threat to that that's outside the
overton window of our order must
therefore be against all of democracy
take a look at this other story from
timecast.com about half of both
republicans and democrats view the other
side as enemies that threaten their
entire way of life wow so maybe it is
true you know maybe
most americans if an election was held
today would vote for donald trump over
joe biden but here's the thing those
americans support donald trump don't
believe an insurrection happened these
are people who probably read the news
watch the news saw what's going on and
they're like that's ridiculous the
narrative isn't true because if they
truly believed that what trump did was a
military coup they probably wouldn't
support him but they don't because
military coup without the military or
without any guns and a bunch of yeah a
bunch of unarmed people and most of us
through open doors
and this will be you know and uh you
know nancy pelosi if you're watching
right you know i think and i said i
think i said this on air she does not
use the internet oh no way i know but
her little acolytes do um
that
i
the disparity here is that the people
inside the media and inside the democrat
party and inside the january 6 committee
say that every single person that showed
up on january 6 was anti-constitution
but if you talk to anybody who was in
the crowd on january 6 right you they
probably every single one of them would
have said no i am for the constitution
you're not following the constitution
and that's why we're here right so in
their mind they are the ones fighting
against a coup you get it right
in a way it's like the easiest solution
because neither one of them intend to
stage a coup they both think the other
one's doing what they're doing
or or
they the other one thinks that they're
doing what they think the other ones do
and like yeah but that's objectively
wrong yeah so how do you unwind that
here here's what i think when i see this
i think this is mostly a product of
the the incoming generation and uh
polarization from the previous
generation
so
i don't think we're seeing this
hyperpolarization just because people
are reading social media and becoming
polarized i think it's that younger
people who are more radicalized by the
previous generation or i think a fair
way to put it is when you look at the
pew graph conservatives have barely
moved to the right at all the left has
gone far left
you have
corporate america
and uh you know liberal parents in big
cities
pushing this heavy indoctrination i mean
my whole whole childhood growing up it
was just endless leftist you know
talking points so these people grow up
living in this world which is far left
they weren't converted to the far left
they have developed in a far-left
mindset yes so as time goes on it is the
new generations that are polarized
against each other what i mean to say is
two millennials one who is far left and
one who is conservative weren't like
previously friends who read a news
article and then went i now disagree
with you oh no why are we enemies these
are people who grew up in entirely
different realities and cannot see the
other side now it is true it is the rule
on the right the right does read
left-wing publications and does follow
left-wing individuals and it is the rule
on the left that they don't we've gone
through the graphs we've pulled up many
of those personalities they don't read
right-wing news so you have the left
that is in a collective in an echo
chamber and the right which you know
looks at both
they're not going to get along i've also
said though that this this one of the
biggest problems on you know of
conservatives or like you know
up until now is that conservatives will
pathologically
deny and reject the notion that pop
culture and hollywood have any effect on
society you know they they say oh no
those are just movies that's not real
don't worry about that whereas as you
just said
there's an inundation of left-wing
talking points out there and a lot of
that is coming through hollywood whether
that be tv movies
in some cases video games now where it's
coming in um and whereas if you're on
the right you're like oh well no we can
just separate that out and it's like no
that's not how it works and i think the
new right is at least finally trying to
get that like software upgrade and
understanding no wait you know
we actually have to do something about
this because but it's amazing because i
will tweet something about this and say
hey i think this tv show or this movie
or whatever it is had a bunch of
influence in this direction and i will
get conservative saying oh that's crazy
that's ridiculous you can't talk about
this but what did barack obama do when
he was in office he would go on late
night shows he would go on comedy he
would do all this stuff he would appear
you know in things and people would say
and people on the right would just laugh
and they would attack it and they say it
was stupid he would go on youtube and
people would attack him and meanwhile on
the left they're like oh i like this guy
this guy's cool and this is the mistake
that the media made with trump when
trump had his well-done steak with
ketchup he had a it was like a 30-day
dry age steak and he was well done with
ketchup yes and the media mocked him for
it but that made him more relatable to
middle america well just really quickly
this is why i think barack obama after
he left office started to work with
netflix with an exclusive deal 100 and i
would even go further than you jack i
wouldn't say it's talking points i would
say it's covert subliminal messaging
that of course is put onto people
through the forms of entertainment it's
not entertainment it's propaganda and it
it's it's fermented in a way where it's
not i don't think it's leftist
ideologies i believe the entire left has
been taken over by a corporate
establishment that is using them as a
conduit to push their agenda to make
people weaker to make people dumber to
make people more
needy for centralization which of course
is going to be granted and given to them
through the multinational corporations
so i think you know i wouldn't even
describe these as leftist ideas but more
of corporatist ideas with them really
calling the shots here from my
perspective is it just fascism
you know like one way big corporations
and government colluding with each other
yeah it's a new kind of digital fascism
i mean that's literal
but also now with the late latest
psychological tricks they could get in
our brain in ways that they never could
before especially with again social
media especially with how we interact
with them and all the information we
give them they have data sets that
dictators would have wished to have that
will again help them conquer the general
public because we're literally giving
them everything about us and when they
know everything they could weaponize
that and use it against us so
you have you guys seen don't look up yet
no of course you've seen it so i thought
it was great one thing i i really
enjoyed it and i enjoyed the social
commentary and people were like lighting
me up for saying that i like this
because everybody gets cured in it but
one thing that i don't think people
realized very well is
the primary antagonist like the main
villain of the movie is a tech oligarch
transhumanist globalist slash bill gates
yeah it's like bill gates
elon musk and like a hillary type no no
it's it shows a picture of the president
hugging bill clinton oh wow yeah like
and and it's irrelevant to the scene
when we were watching luke's like look
clinton clinton clinton and it's like
half a second in the middle of the night
i totally didn't notice that in the
middle of the kids
jumps to a picture of the president
hugging bill clinton for no reason
and i'm like
i get it
at the very right so this i think is
this one of the first times that we've
seen that a tech oligarch has been
portrayed as the villain in a movie
kingsman uh kingsman yeah would be one
the circle i think would be another one
which like nobody has seen even though
it was tom hanks and emma watson they
totally memory hold that one because i
didn't think i saw it i barely remember
it i loved it i thought it really lasted
i thought it was
but one of the key things in don't look
up and that one is that all of what what
lucas was talking about they have all
your data and the way this is played out
in don't look up and it's i thought it
was funny he was like he's like i can
actually predict how you're going to die
down to 96.6
uh percentage and i looked up your
algorithm when when you left the one
thing i remember is you'll die alone
yes yes and there's also that amazon
which i'm not going to spoil it honestly
it was it was wrong that guy if you
remember the ending actually his
prediction was spoiler good i know a
little bit of a spoiler thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you